alright welcome to the video I do a book
review again and this is also an opening
book and it presents um a black
repertoire based on the tirage defense
the terrorists Irish defense is a
defense to the Queen's Gambit we see
them starting position right here after
3c5 the initial moves of course another
typical Queen's Gambit moves here and
then black goes from c5 and a couple of
words about the book in general it's
some published vine quality chess the
system I think um Scottish based
publishing company I think they're in
Glasgow um and they have a tremendous
track record of great opening books or
at other great books I don't think they
ever published an even mediocre book um
this is part of the Grandmaster
repertoire series which is now I think
on till about ten volumes this is one of
ten I don't think that has been one
published after that um and all these
books of tremendous quality so the name
of the publisher is really very much
adequate um the authors of this book
it's a collaboration effort um between
on the one hand down Jakub our guard his
own he's a grandmaster for originally I
think from Denmark and now he's living
and playing he's living in Scotland
of course as his company is based there
and the second author here some nikolaos
neat release and mom certainly spending
this wrong but I apologize to him in
advance in advance for that he
a player and analyst from from Greece
and he's very young he's very competent
and in computer analysis you can see it
in this book it is very much computer
checked but he's also a great opening
expert you can see this for yourself if
you take some time to browse through the
the opening mostly opening em forum of
chess publishing calm
the forum is chess pop calm and tis
great contributor there on all kinds of
openings um so they both put their time
and effort together to to produce this
book it's three hundred and forty page
of pages yeah about three hundred forty
pages and it covers some a black
repertoire here in this opening first of
all I'd like to UM explain why it is
very interesting to to study the
terrorist defense on it has a huge
advantage over almost any other opening
in terms that it is playable against
basically every setup that wide might
choose besides one year for so if you
study and know the terrorists defense
you are pretty much good to go
against anything else but one year for
I'd like to to show you what I am what
I'm implying here let's say um first
let's take a quick look at deform of
course you'll get the Queen's Gambit in
nearly all of your games them of course
there are those side lines based on
Bishop f4 and so on but they are not
really dangerous besides if you look at
this let's say white goes neither three
you go for instance here in order to
reach the tirage very interesting is c5
and if white now wants to go for
instance four
should be for setup let's say C 3 you're
very comfortable here and choosing what
you would you play yourself
you can easily build up the Terrace
formation again and it is arguable that
it cannot be so advantageous for white
to have a porn on C 3 so most of all
you'll get the Queen's Gambit with the
second C form and outer loops after 6:00
and after e6 white will bring one of its
nights out and after both night moves
you play C 5 and you got the cherish
also the terror setup is very easy to
employ against C form of white go c4 you
just play 6 and d5 on the next smooth
and if he goes d4 c5 you got the charge
again the only pretty much independent
way for white to play here our setups
were white basically avoids playing d4
at all for instance he goes g3 then you
can can simply continue with your same
setup and ask basically ask why do you
have anything better than G form if he
goes d4 in this kind of position you
reached your terror setup again this is
also yeah this is basically the mainline
position of the tirage so wide in order
to avoid the Tarrasch would would you
need to play setups like let's say b3
here and then you have a lot of
possibilities you can just continue your
setup here and basically wait for him to
transpose again or white can choose to
to not to do this and then you are free
to go let's say d4 and this is just one
line that is possible here so black
pretty much against anything else but
one e4 can set up this formation if you
just look at the black formation you're
not at the white one just it's a black
one white black goes d5 c5 both Knights
to the natural squares Bishop e7 and
Castle
next move let's say this castle you can
basically play this against anything
with that white might throw at you even
if he completely four goes to occupy the
center let's say D 5c 596 and now for
instance if he wants to avoid you
playing a5 which is also a thing to
consider then you would go d4 you go
Knight f6 castles is 64 and you're back
in the turret so White has basically
yeah maybe this is a bit harsh to say
but yoni has got second rate
alternatives besides allowing the terror
so if you're really on front of this
opening and study study it you have a
nice all-around weapon besides
everything but you form so now the
second part the most important part is
it is it a good opening yeah basically
the Tarrasch enjoys as somewhat yeah
dubiousness may be a bit hard harder
bird but since it's considered slightly
risky for blank and this is mostly due
to one line and it's um this is a main
line also let's say 93 C 5 C takes D 5 e
takes d5 Knight f3 knight c6 g3 Knight
f6 Bishop g2 Bishop e7 castles castles
Bishop g5 this is the old tried and
tested main line here this was
introduced via a keyboard Stein back in
the nineteen I would say twenties maybe
the first games were 19 18 19 or
something but he basically introduced
this setup based on g3 and later Bishop
g5 this is some yeah it's pretty much
agreed that this is the most principled
and best way to fight the tower of
course this confirmation that black has
very often leads to an isolated Queens
pawn
this is most clearly seen if if you look
at the former main line here CTX deform
94 then black goes h6p should be three
and then I think the main move here is
rook e8 this is the old main line of the
tirage defense and you can see that
black at the isolated D pawn on d5 and
white has pretty much an ideal setup to
to come combat this pawn it's got the
bishop on g2 and this was the major
discovery of Rubenstein's that the
bishop on g2 pretty much puts the
maximum pressure on the d5 pawn white
also has to set up with Bishop e3 and
994 so he's got this pond safely located
black has a hard time to ever advance it
and well this position is not entirely
clear that white is really really
enjoying a large advantage is difficult
to play at least and really hard to to
equalize if white knows what is doing so
in this book here on Bishop g5 the
authors suggest to play C form this is
of course an entirely different
structure black advance this is C pawn
and therefore establishes a three to two
majority on the Queen side black has
three points here and white has two
pawns so let's assume that why this is
doing nothing on our next couple of
moves like will amongst other things
prepare to advance B 5 B 4 a 5 and so on
and uses pawn majority they're still the
d5 pawn is an issue white still has
pressure here and
most often he plays on 94 he 5 here to
increase the pressure on the d5 pawn and
um later try to also play maybe b3 to to
attack the c4 on here this whole line is
known for yeah
for decades actually but always had the
reputation of being somewhat better for
white the author though invested an
enormous amount of time and obviously
it's only the amount of novelties and
and really astonishing ideas presented
here can only mean that they invested I
don't know hundreds of hours to to make
this so really an interesting and also
very fighting choice for black thing gum
this kind of position on easily allows
black to to complicate the game of
course if you look at the lines
presented there are a couple of very
very deep analyzed continuations where
on a white can exchange lots of stuff
and you get even end games they really
went as far as move 30 on some lines
which is of course very unrealistic that
you would get this in a let's say normal
tournament game against I don't know a
player rated 2000 or something they will
most likely be out of book after c4 or
maybe two or three moves later I must
say that I played the the white side of
the Queen's Gambit who I don't know 20
years but I never really bothered to to
look this variation up and study it
deeply so if someone would have played
this against me possible I had Bishop g5
this position here numerous times on the
board but no one ever went c4 I pretty
much would have yeah would have been on
my own and have had to sing think myself
and it's not a comfortable picture - if
someone would sit there and knows all
the stuff in this book and you need to
find all this at the bottom that's our
task I'd like to just show you one one
sample line here that they are analyzed
in the book is just is just one example
of really imaginative new ideas
presented here just the second time I
need to look it up quickly in the book
yeah I found it we should be six as a
blacksmith here and now why does that
some sort of crossroads you can play
many moves here like III for instance or
Roop c1 and so on there's a couple of
possibilities but one move you'll
certainly face and I witness it myself
for quite some times because a teammate
of mine is employing this line with leg
and he faced f4 more than once while I
was present so the system moves that is
really played on quite a lot I think
even especially by by players who don't
know the line in detail because it looks
just very tempting to threaten f5 and
this way em increase the pressure on on
d5 also it makes a good impression to to
just fortify your night there and now
the author you present an entirely new
approach the old goof here is nyjah for
this is maybe somewhat better for white
they analyze aged 60 M I just want to
present the quickly the idea which is
which is quite remarkable white captures
here
Bishop h4 s also analyzed I'm now at
five and now you you could ask yourself
what is black doing here
because if you look at this should you
retreat here must be a rather rather
modest way to play let's to say the
least
what what what black is doing he can
capture here
he takes e5 and now likes black girls
form Queen b6 check here King edge one
Queen takes b2 and this is a pretty
amazing position on white mane try here
it's f2 x e6 and now black of course
doesn't capture on t3i anything but just
recaptures so black has sacrificed the
piece here but he got some pawns in the
process black has got 7 points
white only 5 so black already has two
points if five is very weak and the
whole position here is very shaky for
white the c3 Knight is just hanging if 5
is hanging and you've got a highly
tactical position on for instance white
could go a ruk ruk c1 takes here Knight
takes should be 3 rupee 8
ruk c2 Queen b6 and it continues some
from some moves further just to show
that it leads to highly interesting
positions where you can really surprise
your opponent I think it's very unlikely
that they've ever seen this idea I never
saw it just to present one piece of
evidence that it's rather an unknown
line all in all this aphorism is a great
fighting choice and basically if you
solve the Bishop g5 problem and the
tarish then this opening becomes very
interesting um just to show you quickly
what are the other principal tries for
white just to give an overview of this
opening white can um in this position
also try other moves the main move
besides Bishop g5 is D takes e5 Bishop
takes and then Bishop g5 this is another
main line the main difference between
this and the immediate Bishop g5 is that
black has got the chance here to play
deform which of course is an entirely
different kettle of fish compared to the
other line because black actually gets
the chance to advance the D pawn so you
won't have to fight against the knight
blocking this pawn all the time now the
main line here it takes on f6 Queen
takes Knight d5 Queen d8 and then white
place one of those knight moves
to d2 o you want and this is some really
an interesting position which for a long
time actually it's considered quite okay
for black it's certainly interesting to
play because black has ideas to
pressurize the to pawn for instance
and you can also see here a general
feature of this opening Black has really
a great development and freedom fries
pieces this opening really gives you the
chance to enjoy every piece piece play
so I think this is some all in all a
great choice for for for instance a
junior players who maybe like to or
should even try to improve their the
technical play there are calculation
abilities and this is just great to have
such a good piece play here if you
compare it to some more let's say solid
but also most more passive openings
where you you suffer from from lack of
space or or you have to do very
long-winded maneuvering um I think this
kind of position would suit many players
much more compared to other openings
that that are regularly played because
you simply don't have a bad PCM in
general if you look at this kind of
position black has very healthy pieces
the only issue of course is support
formation and this is can just be
evaluated with concrete lines of white
can do something against the somewhat
shaky pawns here from a dynamic point of
view blacks position is just fine with
all pieces active um an interesting line
that they present in this book and this
is also a remarkable feature um they
actually present two lines that are
virtually unknown almost unknown I would
say that really posed serious problems
for the opening and they actually
present these options for white and try
to provide decent antidotes against them
so they're basically sort of here
looking into the future what kinds of
arm problems white might can
with so lines that are not so well known
but are dangerous even covered here so
you're even good to go against some at
the moment lesser-known lines that might
become popular I'm pretty sure that will
become more popular one line for
instance he is DC v Bishop takes e5 at a
three this is some really interesting
recent try I played this myself in the
German it was quite funny in the German
club club cap competition and I played
it with white I played this position
with white and I only learned of this
line because of this book which I
purchased actually for for playing this
opening is black but I found this line
as being interesting so I tried it out
and my opponent actually he had this
book but he hadn't yeah he didn't find
the time yet to to study it so after the
game he needed to look at what what is
presented there and I can assure you
that the the main tries on there that
are played up to now not really
satisfactory for black he old so he
didn't know what is recommended in the
book and got a really bad position
quickly
I'm the authors actually prevents a
remarkable move 94 here which is I think
pretty much impossible for for a human
player to to find over the board
he didn't even consider it very
understandably and this sound leads to
enormous complications after White's
response this might be Queen d5 495 I
don't want to really go into detail here
they present some really interesting in
deep analysis and trying to justify this
move 94 but it's just remarkable usually
you you have books where the author's
simply try to sort of hide the critical
lines that endanger their opening and
they actually put these interesting
lines here forward and try to try to you
Aliza this is one of the lines another
line that they present is here is here
detects e5 which is also virtually
unknown but seems quite interesting try
for white they do some really lengthy
analysis here just to show quickly deep
black must play d4 doesn't have any
alternatives here d5 is hanging so it
sits d4 Knight f4 here maybe there are
some other tries like Bishop f5 but
ultimately they didn't make them work so
this kind of thing in comm develops here
and now White has Bishop d2 s and as an
option or Queen d2 and I'm not quite
sure what's actually more critical this
one on my tubes or Queen d2 not quite
sure but just you just mention this kind
of line is also not very much known
anthem they anticipate that this line
would become more popular as an
alternative for white and try to defuse
this as well I think with quite quite
noise analysis
um one also nice feature about the
cherish if you look at the starting
position here is that quite often
against them let's aim not so
theoretically on well-versed opposition
you would get sidelines which are
entirely harmless
if white doesn't go for the Rubinstein
setup was g3 here g3 or and let's say he
he studied this kind of stuff and tries
to present you concrete problems then
you're pretty much okay instantly
let's look quickly at alternatives then
white might have a lot of players
actually play III which yeah from a
modern perspective looks really passive
but actually was considered by my doctor
tirage who invented thought of this
opening as the best reply okay Knight f6
93 and now the authors suggest a six
which is a very very flexible move quite
often um black gets an isolated pawn
here as well this kind of structure but
the major difference is that white will
develop his Bishop just to e2 not to
cheat not to g2 and therefore he will
have lots of a clearly less pressure
than after g3 let's say there should be
296 castles castles b3 and then black
very often puts his pieces and develops
his pieces and if quite similar fashion
like this let's say Queen d6 Bishop a7
and so on it's just a typical isolated
composition where black enjoys a really
great priests peace play and maybe even
some attacking chances on on whites king
with let's say route d8 we should be
eight threatening on h2 this is a very
typical position where basically White
has absolutely nothing it's just just a
nice position for black to play and also
take note of the really great piece
activity here so it's just just a fine
kind of position for players who like to
to have active aggressive piece play um
but III is played quite often on on an
amateur level often white players would
go Knight f3 also and now you have the
choice you can play knight c6 and try to
supposed to to a mainline or maybe
better you can also take here 94 96 and
I don't want to want to go deeply into
this Black has already equalized here
and sometimes even nice chances to take
the initiative let's say move like g3
here blacken can easily grab the
initiative and yeah I think like it's
already better in this kind of position
so the sidelines are not so promising
white can also try to deviate at the
later stage let's say in this position
he could try for four solid development
certainly the decent move which
basically tries for this III kind of
setups but with the bishop actively
deployed here and now the authors
analyzed c4 which is quite similar
looking to this Rubinstein line with the
9 c4 and this leads to very interesting
positions where black goes for Bishop b4
maybe exchange on c3 and then put a
knight on e4 black enjoys this majority
again so it's got a clear plan of
advancing his pawns there
all in all it's it's a nice fighting
position here for black one one thing
I'd like to mention is that you can also
employ the Tarot setup only in specific
cases if you want to it's really very
interesting in terms of move orders
let's say you are you usually start your
game like this with black and white
white plays g3 so you get the Catalan
black has lots of options here of course
but let's say B should be 793
cancels castles and here black usually
takes on c4 so let's say you like the
lines presented in the book after g3 the
scarred or c4 lines so why not play c5
here why doesn't have anything else
really then to transpose into the main
line to rush so the tirage main line
here can also be quite an interesting
way to to play against the Catalan if
you are looking for some way to to
combat the Catalan opening and you're
not satisfied maybe with these positions
which can be really yeah really tedious
to play with black black has quite good
chances to equalize the game but it very
often will be very young yeah
to be honest boring kind of equalizing
process so if you want to fight more
then c5 can be an interesting option
here and it will lead to a much more
complex game than F then D takes c4
awesome you could try to reach the
cherish room via some some quite
interesting move waters of course the
most straightforward way to play here
would be e65 and this way to head for
the trash but there are even
possibilities to reach it why are c5
okay you might ask how is this possible
yet so it's easily possible let's say
white place 93 you go Knight f6 he goes
Knight f3 d6 and the next move will be
d5 Knight c6 and so on let's say g3 d5
and wider as black is threatening deform
will have nothing better than this and
you're back in the g3 oops
in the g3 turret so there are many many
ways to to reach this opening this move
order would have the advantage to for
instance avoid
to avoid this kind of line if you for
instance know that your opponent likes
to play this line but you start the game
with c4 you can try to trick him into
the charge via one c5 yeah there are
lots of move order possibilities here
and this is really due to the universal
approach of the Terror setup I can
really heavily recommend this book it
can be a really nice addition to your
opening repertoire and that would also
heavily recommend this opening in
general for for club players and and the
junior players because it leads to two
really nice open please play and you are
simply not in danger of suffering with a
bad piece the whole game I see this time
and time again that that players for
instance play let's say the Kings Indian
have the dead Bishop on g7 or play some
some classical Queen's Gambit let's say
let's say this kind and they are not
really well versed in in the details and
suffer from the c8 bishop the whole game
they play C 6 and a 6 and so on they
don't do though the proper maneuvers
here to free this bishop and this won't
happen in the tirage because you don't
have a bad piece there you never run
this risk the worst thing that can
happen is that you get is slightly
exposed D pawn and if this pawn get gets
lost after you did some some inaccurate
moves then you can still fight to find a
pawn down but you don't suffer the
danger of a bad piece the whole game IAM
it just guarantees you a free replete
pre pre pre sorry every piece play and
what I'd like to notice
that this book really focuses on the
main lines I mentioned so it doesn't
cover stuff like this here this is a
rather interesting actually a gambit
line this this kind of stuff is not
covered down also it focus absolutely
exclusively on the c4 line the c4 line
here in the main um in the main
continuation here it doesn't cover at
all C takes d4 this is really important
to note so on it's a repertoire based
approach but this is really sensible in
this case because the lines that are
selected very carefully selected are
presented in so much detail that it
would be young would be very hard to
justify to to show all kinds of possible
side lines here that are at least
according to the authors not
satisfactory anyway so it concentrates
on the lines you you need to know for
this opening to to work and does a great
job of presenting the ins and outs there
I'll post the link to to further
information about the book and yeah
thanks for watching and if you'd like to
have more book reviews or maybe even
yeah a special subject or special book
that you'd like me to review I'm not
sure that I have the book but the book
that you might suggest but feel free to
come up with suggestions here yeah
thanks for watching and we'll see you
soon with the new video